i remember ross had talked to you and
nip at that time and wiz at that time
yeah um how seriously those talks um
well where mmg
that was more like uh um obviously i was
a lot younger than i was still in man
was a big fan of rick ross you know what
i mean so that out that was more
predicated on
you know somebody that was heavy in the
game and still is and somebody like
myself who was up and coming who hoped
to be you know get good at this [ __ ] get
great at this and just trying to learn
you know like
from them um i had other situations with
major labels that was a lot closer to
being
a real you know situation but again when
it came down to ownership and to opm
being represented the right way in the
deal it never really sat right with me
they never really saw the full full
potential of like what it what it was
that i wanted to do and what we was
capable of doing so again it was easy
for me to say no because if all i was
gonna be diminished to was like an
artist on trial
i had passed that all the artists that
they was trying to do that way i had did
more shows than them already
you know i'm saying like i had sold more
t-shirts than them already you know like
we was doing venues like i wasn't
interested in none of that you know i
was not genuinely in my heart i was
never really interested in any of that